Hallo zusammen.
Erst einmal herzlichen Dank
für die vielen Reaktionen
zu meinem "DOK" der letzten Woche,
"Pandemie-Vorsorge: Mangelhaft".
Vielen Dank
für die vielen positiven Reaktionen.
Ich und das ganze Team
haben uns sehr darüber gefreut.
Euer Lob spornt uns an,
so weiterzumachen.
Ich möchte die Fragen beantworten,
die sich mit der Pandemievorsorge,
dem eigentlichen Thema des Films,
befassen.
Ich habe nicht alles recherchiert,
kann nicht alles beantworten.
Die erste Frage von Thomas Walker:
Welches Bundesamt
ist für das Outsourcing
des Ethanol-Lagers zuständig?
Das Ethanol-Lager
wurde nicht wirklich outgesourced.
Der Ethanol-Markt wurde liberalisiert
und ALCO Suisse,
das früher dem Bund gehörte,
wurde per Anfang 2019 privatisiert.
Dadurch ist das frühere Bundeslager
von ALCO Suisse weggefallen.
Die Schaffung von Pflichtlagern
wäre nötig gewesen
und zwar von privaten Firmen.
Dafür zuständig,
ob es ein Pflichtlager gibt,
ist die wirtschaftliche
Landesversorgung.
Dieses spezielle Gebilde haben wir
im Film in einer Grafik gezeigt:
ein kleines Bundesamt,
das nur ein Sekretariat
einer grosse Wirtschaftsmiliz ist.
Diese Wirtschaftsmiliz -
Chemie- und Pharmaspezialisten -
sagte im Februar 2019,
es brauche kein Pflichtlager.
Dann die nächste Frage
von Ursula Nyffenegger:
Sie sagt, jetzt wäre der Moment,
die früheren Fehler auszumerzen,
und das Lager mit Ethanol zu füllen.
Genau das passiert jetzt, Ursula.
Der Bundesrat hat beschlossen,
dass er wieder ein Lager will.
Das Parlament hat letzte Woche
den Kredit von 5,82 Mio. gesprochen.
Das sollte
für 6'000 t Ethanol reichen.
ALCO Suisse muss jetzt
dieses Lager wieder schaffen.
Wir sind quasi
gleich weit wie Anfang 2019,
weil ALCO Suisse
die Mehrheit des Marktes hat.
Da es immer noch
eine weltweite Pandemie gibt,
besteht die Schwierigkeit darin,
ob und wie schnell ALCO Suisse
die 6'000 t auf dem Markt findet.
Es eilt, denn wir möchten
für eine zweite Welle gewappnet sein.
Weshalb hat der Bund die Masken,
die einige Jahre vor der Pandemie
an Lager waren,
nicht einfach an Heime verkauft?
Das Maskenlager
wurde vor der Schweinegrippe,
ungefähr im Jahr 2007, angelegt.
Man spricht bei Masken von einem
Verfallsdatum von etwa vier Jahren.
Also bereits nach der Schweinegrippe
waren sie kurz vor dem Verfall,
weshalb man sie wohl nicht an Kantone
und Spitäler verkaufen wollte.
Dann hatte man die Idee,
die Masken nicht beim Bund zu lagern,
wo sie eher verfallen,
sondern in Spitälern und Heimen, wo
die Masken täglich verwendet werden.
Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee,
doch es gab nur eine Empfehlung,
keine Verpflichtung für die
Institutionen, die Masken zu lagern.
Roman sagt, das Altersheim im Film
habe komplett versagt,
sei nicht auf eine Pandemie
vorbereitet gewesen.
Und er fragt, ob ein Altersheim
keinen Notvorrat habe.
Im Film wurde ein Pflegeheim gezeigt.
Pflege-, Altersheime und andere
Institutionen haben Notvorräte,
z.B. an Masken.
Doch sie sind eher
für den Alltag ausgerüstet,
kennen z.B. das sog. Norovirus.
Auch dafür braucht es Masken, aber
viel weniger als bei einer Pandemie.
Weil, wie gesagt,
der Bund nur eine Empfehlung
für Masken ausgesprochen hat,
war, wie im Film gesehen,
dem Pflegeheim Aergera
der Pandemieplan
nicht einmal bekannt.
Dann eine Frage von Daniel Definti,
ob wohl die vielen Ämter
das eigentliche Problem seien.
Ich glaube, das kann man so sagen.
Das zeigt der Film.
Neben der umstrittenen Kostenfrage.
Das sagte auch Gesundheits-
rechtsprofessor Christoph Zinger.
Er spricht von einer
"Verantwortungsdiffusion"
oder sogar von organisierter Verant-
wortungslosigkeit der vielen Ämter.
Ich kann ein Beispiel nennen:
Hauptverantwortlich für die Pandemie-
vorsorge sind zwei Departemente
mit zwei Ämtern und zwei Gesetzen.
Einerseits
das Departement des Inneren EDI
mit dem Bundesamt für Gesundheit
und dem Epidemiengesetz,
auf der anderen Seite
das Wirtschaftsdepartement WBF
mit der
wirtschaftlichen Landesversorgung
und dem Landesversorgungsgesetz.
Die Verantwortlichkeiten gehen
über zwei Departemente und Gesetze.
Deshalb schlägt Gesundheits-
rechtsprofessor, Herr Zenger, vor,
dass die Gesundheitsvorsorge
nur noch beim Bundesamt
für Gesundheit gemacht werden soll.
Welche Fragen haben wir noch?
Jemand sagt, es sei an der Zeit,
Verwaltungsstellen auszumisten
oder noch besser sie aufzuheben.
Die Forderung
nach Ausmisten oder gar Aufheben
ist sicher provokativ gemeint,
das geht nicht.
Aber die Ämter
müssen ihren gesetzlichen Auftrag
sicher stärker wahrnehmen.
Wie gehört reicht eine Empfehlung
für Maskenvorräte nicht.
Mirjam Siemann fragt:
Braucht es eine humanere Wirtschaft,
damit man keine Angst
vor Verantwortung mehr hat?
Sie spielt wohl auf die
wirtschaftliche Landesversorgung an.
Diese wird seit Anfang Januar
in einer Administrativuntersuchung
überprüft.
Bundesrat Parmelin selbst
hat sie in Auftrag gegeben.
Es geht darum,
dass es nicht sein kann,
dass ein kleines Bundesamt nur
im Auftrag der Wirtschaft arbeitet,
woraus klare Interessenskonflikte
von wirtschaftlicher Seite entstehen.
Man muss das Bundesamt stärken.
Das Bundesamt müsste Vorgaben
an die Wirtschaft machen,
was an Lager sein muss -
selbstverständlich
nach Absprache mit Spezialisten.
Ich denke, andererseits
ist es höchstproblematisch,
dass der Leiter der Vorsorge
in diesem Amt
40 % für das Bundesamt arbeitet
und sonst in der Wirtschaft ist.
Der Gesundheitsrechtprofessor
Christoph Zenger sagt,
man sehe,
wie marginal dieses Amt sei,
wie wenig politische Bedeutung
man der Vorsorge in der Schweiz gibt.
Dann ein kritisches Votum
von Andi Schär.
Er sagt, er fände es kontraproduktiv,
einen Schuldigen zu suchen.
Ich kann das verstehen.
Mein Anspruch an diese Recherche
war allerdings nicht,
einen Schuldigen zu finden,
sondern zu schauen,
wie die Pandemieplanung
in der Schweiz organisiert ist,
wer dafür zuständig ist.
Ich kann ein Beispiel
zur Schuldfrage nennen:
Wenn man von einem Maskenvorrat
für eine Pandemie ausgeht,
haben wir eine Eidgenössische
Kommission für Pandemievorbereitung,
eine Expertenkommission, angesiedelt
beim Bundesamt für Gesundheit.
Sie muss sagen, wie viele Masken
es für einen Pandemiefall braucht.
Dann haben wir das Bundesamt für
wirtschaftliche Landesversorgung
beim Wirtschaftsdepartement,
das schaut, dass alles läuft,
dass die Empfehlungen
oder die Vorschläge der Kommission
umgesetzt werden.
Für die Umsetzung zuständig
sind die Kantone
bzw. die Spitäler oder Pflegeheime.
Wer ist also schuld?
Ich kann nur sagen: Laut
Epidemiengesetz ist es der Bundesrat.
Er hat die letzte Verantwortung,
dass die Bevölkerung Heilmittel hat.
Z.B. Arzneimittel oder Hygienemasken.
Dann noch eine gute Schlussfrage:
Wie könnten Bundesrat und Behörden
das verspielte Vertrauen
zurückgewinnen?
Wie meistens in solchen Fällen
mit schonungsloser Offenheit,
mit einer klaren Kommunikation.
Bundesrat Berset sagt im Film,
man werde das Ganze
selbstverständlich aufarbeiten,
man werde sicher zu den Fehlern
stehen und diese klar kommunizieren.
Er sagt, momentan
bewältige er noch eine Krise.
Das kann man so sehen,
die Fallzahlen steigen.
Gleichzeitig hätte ihm gut
angestanden, einiges anzusprechen.
Die Geschäftsprüfungskommission
des Parlaments
arbeitet jetzt die ganze Krise auf.
Das hat sie bereits im Frühling
angekündigt.
Ich denke, wir können bis ungefähr
Ende Jahr einen Bericht erwarten.
Das war's für den Moment.
Vielen Dank für euer Interesse.
Wenn ihr weitere Fragen habt,
könnt ihr die posten.
Wenn ihr mehr solche Filme sehen
möchtet, abonniert unseren Kanal.
Tschüss zusammen.